what is happening with the the skater
boy movie everybody like people lost
their collective minds when they found
out that this thing was happening
um so
finally um i'm
turning the skater boy song into a film
um
this is something that i've been working
on for a while and i'm really excited
like there's just like i took my high
school experience threw it into
a song
and now we're just gonna dive deeper and
it's going to be in a film about an
extension an extension of this song and
the message in it
do you have like a dream casting list
for it because i mean off the top of my
head i'm like i don't know how whether
you know but mgk megan fox to me makes a
little bit of sense i don't know if
their ages match up to what you're
looking for but do you have do you have
dream casting in mind would they work
like i am definitely hitting up my
friends
and my musician friends to make cameos
in this because it'll be really fun yeah
for sure like i was i was talking to
mark hoppus the other day i was like
mark you have to make it cameo in my
skater boy movie and he was like i'm in
and i like i felt like he could be like
a cool teacher or like something in it
uh what's your relationship because with
skater boy and you know we're at 20
years now since uh since the album came
out what's your relationship like now as
uh as a woman to
those songs do you do do you still have
the same relationship with them from the
first album yeah
yeah
you do cause some people don't know
i relate to my thoughts still i do still
that's but you have to understand that's
like that's a rare thing that's a rare
thing for an art artist go sometimes
years without playing the stuff off
their first albums they're like coming
they came from me i've written on all of
my songs
and all all seven albums and just as a
songwriter like
the stuff that i put out is very
important like the messaging and
the the you know these songs come from
me i believe in them and uh
you know
like to this day yeah i mean it's so
special to have songs
that the audience and people are still
connecting to and like
the younger generation is discovering
like the other days uh one of my friends
texted me like a bunch of like
five-year-old girls singing like
complicated and i was like dude it's so
crazy like they
the newer younger generation knows my
songs that have been around for 20 years
um so it's been such a blessing and um i
still love performing like all my hits
from over the years because it's like
when you achieve that and
you know
with what happened to me
like with my my music taking off and at
the level it did that's just so unique
and special and that's something i'm
really proud of and when i perform those
songs live i i can feel and see the
audience um
moved and there's nothing like it do you
um
do you ever sort of sit and try and
figure out
when the moment was where you realized
that things were just never going to be
the same like was there one moment where
you knew that you had just taken a
spaceship into you know to the moon and
that there was just no coming back for
you
when fame hit
i was always really focused and really
serious and like driven and hardworking
um i had lots of fun but like i i feel
like
i was just like no i have to keep going
like i really like like that but like i
remember when i won my first
moon man
so that was like best new artist for the
mtv awards
that's when i was like whoa it happened
like i'm on like a little girl watching
like award shows on tv and of course i
dreamed of
having
my music be heard and like being part of
an award show and performing and winning
awards and like when that happened and i
like i was like oh my god and i think i
probably like blacked out and it was
like i remember thanking the munch music
awards at the same time
you are what you there's there's a few
people who you know when they started
out the one thing they didn't want to be
was a fashion icon who inadvertently
wound up being a fashion icon and you've
always been a fashion icon can i show
you a few pictures and just get some
quick reaction from you just from some
of your looks from over the years is
that okay so let's start with that let's
start with the classic right here
ah
i love me a baggy camo pants
and then like i don't know i like put a
canadian flag on my tie this was the mtv
awards probably back in like 2002 or
something and yeah that was that was
let's see if we can get another one
that's not my cat that's my cat so we'll
go the other way here
what about that
then you know i went on to have a
fashion line called abby dawn and that
was a new york uh fashion week and i had
my first probably my first runway show
and that was a custom abbey dawn dress
i love that and classic classic
my first year at the grammys
i was like i'm not wearing a dress i
want to wear a tuxedo
and um and then decked it out and kind
of made it my own
um and then there's one more here that i
want to oh two more here that i want to
get to this is one of my favorites i
love that
cool
that was a i heart radio festival in las
vegas and
um
that was my stage outfit yeah and i like
to like put like half of my head up and
braids sometimes so
i was experimenting with that i i'll say
one of the things that you've always
you've always had is when you look at
you on a red carpet you always look like
you're dressed for fun you know what i
mean even in something even in something
like that right
yeah
yeah i love that outfit um pink is one
of my favorite colors and
yeah
same same um international women's day
is uh coming up and
one of the the it's on march 8th and i
want to just talk to you quickly about
when you presented olivia rodrigo with
the songwriter of the year award at
variety's annual hit makers when you see
somebody like olivia rodrigo who had one
of those years where they had a song
that shook the world and their life
changed forever do you see a little bit
of yourself in a young artist when
they've had a year that you've also had
when it's a young woman
absolutely
um well i'm just like so
it's so nice to see
like a younger female artist singer
songwriter
um
putting out music and it just like
doing so well and and reaching such a
wide audience with olivia it's like
she's everyone loves her um of all ages
and yeah i mean i think the that the
the thing the common thread is like um i
started out also like super young and i
think there's something
really cool about that when you're
writing at a young age before you know
it's all happens and you're out there
and you know you don't really even know
how big it's going to be like you don't
really like yeah
you can really open up and i think also
at that age you know really going
through a lot as a young woman and
experiencing like heartbreak and love
for the first time and those types of
raw emotions so i think like
that's also
what's really cool what's so great about
you know billy
and her writing at such a young olivia
writing at such a young age is
you know it's like it's so real and raw
and new to them and they they're hitting
an audience it's also like going through
that for the first time and people can
relate
when did you get good at being famous or
do you think you are good at being
famous
it's a tough thing
i mean i was always like terrible at
doing interviews because i was like i'm
i'm more of a quiet person so like when
i was younger it was like very strange
like i was like okay i write songs i go
in the studio and i sing
but then there's like all these
interviews and like all this other stuff
that comes along with it that's like not
music and so like
there's like so much work involved like
you're traveling you're on an airplane
every day different city different bed
and um
and that was like a surprise to me but
like you know
i was really
just in love with music and would do
anything for it and what was happening
was so special at the time and i
literally did gave my entire life to my
music career and
here i am 20 years later
my seventh album love sucks
and i'm about to go on tour this year
and finally album's coming out this year
and i'm still enjoying music and loving
it so much and having a blast with it
um i want to burn through some things uh
here i think we may have done this
before you with you before it's a
celebrity confessions i'm just gonna
fire off a couple quick questions you
let me know
some quick answers okay
uh what's your favorite indulgence like
a cheat meal if you have a cheat meal
like what's your like what's your thing
um pizza pizza uh who's the most famous
person ever slide into your dms
um
[Music]
drake
okay there we go
um
when was the last was the last time you
cried watching a tv show or movie
i can't remember
do you cry often
no
no you don't
just uh
once a month
and uh and finally anybody any anybody
anybody anybody so dead or alive who
would be your ultimate celebrity duet
partner
uh i would say kurt cobain
kirk cobain obviously i mean i could say
why kurt cobain but i really like you
don't even need to say why kurt cobain
i know
legend and legend legend uh and uh
quickly before we go i know fans have
been dying dying to see you live and
you've had some shows and covet happen
and postponements and everything else
it's been a very long time um if you
could let fans know who have been
waiting years to see you live what they
can expect from the new live show
um
the love sucks tour my new live show
we'll have
it'll be just a lot of fun i think for
everybody for me after not playing for
so long because of the pandemic for
everybody coming out
um i think we'll have like a lot of
energy
and it'll be
it'll be a fun musical journey um
hearing songs from all of my albums into
this new record
amazing uh congratulations i know julia
has some things that she's going to ask
you just a couple of liners and stuff
but it's so good to see you the album is
so much fun and you look and sound
dynamite and uh congratulations thanks
so much for this
thank you very much
you